neuf ans laurent wauquiez le plus jeune
député de france comme jacques barrot il
ya 30 ans était le benjamin l'hémicycle
marié un enfant ce jeune diplômé maître
des requêtes au conseil d'état a
commencé ses études au collège cévenol
au chambon-sur-lignon en haute-loire
avant les poursuivre à lyon paris et
strasbourg
il est entré en politique en 2002 comme
suppléant de jacques barrot pour cette
première journée en tant que député
laurent wauquiez n'a pas sacrifié sa
traditionnelle course à pied dans les
sous bois du vivarais lignon
c'est important d'avoir une bonne
condition physique c'est très important
gardez l'équilibré son équilibre il le
trouve aussi auprès de ses amis des gens
qu'il aime rencontrer une attitude qui
ressemble à celle de son prédécesseur
c'est sûr que jacques barrot m'a
énormément apporté il m'a donné le sens
du service de l'efficacité
et puis de la tolérance par rapport aux
autres mais en même temps je suis pas là
pour être un héritier je suis là pour
proposer un avenir
après des semaines de campagne c'est une
nouvelle vie qui commence il faut
réaliser fatigué c'est sûr mais en même
temps très heureux de la confiance comme
fait la haute-loire et puisqu'elle met
suivi sur ma campagne de terrain sans
attaques personnelles maintenant il va
falloir s'organiser j'ai du mal à
réaliser que je deviens députés et faire
en même temps de travail ici et puis en
faire remonter à l'assemblée nationale
au conseil général de la haute-loire le
nouveau président se réjouit à l'idée de
pouvoir travailler de concert avec le
nouveau député est une grande joie aussi
pour le conseil général car nous avons
une identité de deux visions des visions
politiques c'est vrai puis surtout une
identité dans le style d'un homme
politique prêt de près de nos
concitoyens qu'on veut voir et qu'ils
ont eue qu'ils ont bien démontré pendant
toute la campagne
tout au long de la journée laurent
wauquiez a rencontré ses amis celles et
ceux qui l'ont soutenu dans cette
campagne
il sait que dès demain il sera souvent à
paris
[Musique]